[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here this is the new
oneplus 10t
and it's
the most
generic oneplus phone
of all time so while i'm not reviewing
this phone this is my first impressions
i have had it for about a week and a
half but i also was busy winning club
ultimate frisbee world championship for
the past eight days in the middle of
ohio with the new york club team pony
anyway typically the t phone for oneplus
is just taking whatever their latest and
greatest was and giving it a spec bump
across the board to just make it a
little bit faster in every way sort of
like what the s used to be for the
iphone but this isn't a direct sequel we
have the oneplus 10 pro in january looks
pretty similar but that was 8.99 when it
launched now it's 7.99 so just keep this
in the back your head as you're watching
this this isn't a 10 t pro
it's just the 10 t and so it launches at
6.49 so on one hand now we know okay
this is a lower price we know to expect
some things to be cut some shortcuts to
be taken to get to this price here but
on the other hand
some of the shortcuts that they took are
downright head scratchers to me so the
oneplus 10 pro from january had the
snapdragon 8 gen 1 chip and up to 12
gigs of ram so this 10 t has a new
snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 and up to 16
gigs of ram great so there's a spec bump
a reason to get this phone cool and
they're nearly the same size but last
year's phone had 120 hertz display
curved pretty dramatically over the
edges this 10t is flat it also has a
thousand hertz touch sample rate and
gets a little bit brighter it is also
adaptive instead of ltpo and it's 1080
instead of 1440. this all makes complete
sense i mean ltpo and especially 1440p
are sort of reserved for the highest end
of phones so at this price 1080p oled
120hz adaptive refresh rate it's good
it's got the fingerprint reader under
the display it's got the hole punch in
the top middle no surprises here design
wise though the 10 pro was a satin soft
touch black that i really liked with a
dark satin metal rails that was kind of
sick actually the 10t here has a new
black textured back called moonstone
black it's got these little dashes or
lines through it
and then instead of dark rails it has
sort of normal generic chrome ones for
their new 360 antenna system and instead
of a camera shelf it's more of a
smoothed out camera slope up to the
shelf which i actually kind of do like
but i liked it first on an oppo phone
that came out a while ago so now it
feels even more like another oppo phone
again adding to the list of reasons why
it feels a bit more generic then you
might also remember oneplus signed this
big three year deal 100 plus million
dollar deal with hasselblad for their
cameras which would let them borrow
maybe some color science or some image
processing and the oneplus 10 pro was a
part of that in january it had the
hasselblad branding on the back and even
a hasselblad themed camera app
well less than two years later this
oneplus 10t
doesn't have any hasselblad stuff
anywhere there's no hasselblad camera
app there's no hasselblad branding on
the back of the phone and as far as i
can tell it doesn't appear to use any of
that new color science or image
processing either now is that because
the cheaper phone isn't worthy of the
new hasselblad sauce like it's not it's
not expensive enough to get that
or is it just because you stopped caring
about it i don't really know i guess i
feel like if you've already paid for it
you should just put it in all your
phones but it's not here and then you
might have also noticed that this is the
first one plus phone ever made
that doesn't have the alert slider
literally one of my favorite features of
any oneplus phone that they've had for
years the three-way volume slider that
lets you quickly switch between sound on
and vibration and silent it is now gone
from the oneplus 10t and they gave their
reason for it you know it takes up more
space than you would think inside the
phone the board has to come across and
we saved that extra space and gave you a
little more battery blah blah blah
you can still do that stuff with
software i actually believe you but like
just think about identity for a second
can you actually imagine the iphone
dropping the mute switch because apple
wants to save some space and prioritize
something else inside the phone i
literally can't picture an iphone not
having a mute switch like sure you can
always do it with software yes but that
i would bet anyone a million dollars
right now that the next five years of
iphones will all have a mute switch
because it's just such a part of the
iphone's design so you know a new one
plus phone coming out and not having an
alert slider it might be kind of minor
to some people who have never bought a
oneplus phone before or never even
followed or cared about the oneplus
stuff but to people who have
this is kind of sad that it's not here
uh just more generic points for this
phone the 10 pro had a standard camera
an ultra wide and a telephoto plus an
led flash with some text in the middle
we talked about how that was kind of
dumb text but it was there to no one's
surprise that text is all gone and in
true generic fashion they've moved to a
sony imx 766 sensor for the primary
which is the same one that was in the
nothing phone and the zenfone 9 and the
rog phone 6 and a bunch of others it
also has a 12 megapixel ultrawide camera
and a 2
megapixel
macro camera
more generic points now probably the
biggest feature headlining this phone
like the one that gets emphasized the
most from oneplus when they tell me
about this phone is the battery so it's
a 4 800 milliamp hour dual cell battery
which is slightly smaller than the 10
pros 5000 milliamp hours but it now
charges with oppo's supervooc technology
at a crazy fast a crazy fast 125 watts
it actually comes with this brick in the
box which says 160 watts on it but the
phone peaks at 125 watts here in the us
and that's good for 1 to 100
in literally 20 minutes it's insane like
it really is truly incredibly convenient
i did a whole video all about fast
charging pretty recently but with this
one i got it down to 20
doing some demos plugged it in for 30
seconds and it got up to 22
and then i let it go for another three
minutes and it got to 32 just easy so i
guess that does feel like oneplus even
though it's opposed superview charging
they've always emphasized fast charging
here
but they also
didn't put wireless charging in this
phone
so you know you get the peace of mind of
having fast charging but you lose the
convenience of wireless charging
even more generic points the funny thing
is despite my disappointment i i bet
this is a perfectly fine phone for a lot
of people decent screen high-end chip
lots of ram pretty smooth performance
from my first impressions decent cameras
and an oxygen os that's more like color
os than ever before that's actually what
a lot of people are looking for at 650
bucks and hey it's even getting four
years of software updates and i guess
that's the point which is this phone is
more generic than ever before which to
me or someone who's familiar with the
oneplus story and the history of the
brand and all that is pretty
disappointing but that also means
by definition that this phone appeals to
more people than ever before so this
goes right in line with what i talked
about in my what happened to oneplus
video if you haven't already watched it
i'll make it the first link below like
button because you should definitely
watch that video but uh yeah i remember
i tweeted a couple days ago when we
first got some of the specs of this
phone that it seems like a new oneplus
phone without an alert slider feels like
them just completely giving up on their
identity and it was funny so many of the
replies were like actually it feels like
a couple years ago when carl pay left
that's when they gave up on their
identity and other people were like
actually no the oneplus 7 pro was the
last good phone they ever made then it
went downhill some people were like the
oneplus 3 was the last time they ever
made a good phone and then every phone
since then was just trash but at the end
of the day this is just my first
impression and the moral of this story
for me is don't be a fan of the company
be a fan of the product the individual
product and if you look at this on the
market today this phone is fine
i'm sure it's fine everything about this
phone it's all right nothing too crazy
about it and that's what they're
intending to do with the sort of
remnants of what oneplus is there's a
lot of other good phones out there for
the price and i highly encourage
checking them out again this sort of
sweet spot of 600 dollars which is like
a lot to spend on a phone but also sort
of right in the middle now considering
you have thousand dollar flagships
there's a lot of competition there i
just reviewed the zenfone 9 incredible
phone for the price i really like it uh
and so a lot of comparables but hey when
you're familiar with oneplus this phone
is just feeling
more generic than ever before
either way that's been it
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]